tonight joe biden will be delivering his
first
joint uh address uh his first address to
a joint session of the house and senate
but it's not called the state of the
union address often in a president's
first year
the state of the union is just not
called the state of the union and
sometimes it's not
um in february or january it's coming in
april and we will be live tonight
on youtube twitch and facebook with joe
biden's first
address to a joint session of the house
and senate we
now have learned that tonight joe biden
will propose
a 1.8 trillion dollar plan which will
include
national paid family leave universal
pre-k
free community college subsidized child
care and a whole bunch of other things
now
will it pass as proposed tonight of
course not
of course not it never does that's the
same with every president this is the
starting point
but joe biden will be introducing his
american families plan
tonight it is part two of the so-called
build back better economic agenda
there's
the two trillion roughly infrastructure
and jobs plan that was released earlier
this month
this is now going to be the next piece
of it a 1.8 trillion dollar package
it is being called a generational
investment in the future it is billed as
something that will help us compete with
china
it will transform the us economy and it
includes one trillion dollars in
spending over the next 10 years
and an additional 800 billion which
would be targeted tax credits for
middle-class
families the proposal also includes
cracking down on tax loopholes used by
high income tax filers
um joe biden wants to nearly double the
capital gains rate from 20 to nearly 40
percent for households making over a
million dollars a year
i don't think that's going to happen but
it's nice that he's proposing it
225 billion dollars for national paid
leave another 225 billion for child care
and of course republicans have already
been criticizing it
they will be against it in their
rebuttal tonight to joe biden's speech
they will come out against it
what's my thought about this i think
that it is a very
reasonable initial framework we've
talked before about oh but how will we
pay for it
first of all that's never asked about
how do we buy missiles
it's never asked about how we pay for
war it's never asked about how we pay
for tax cuts for the rich
it's asked by republicans when it's
actual
programs that they believe are either
wasteful
or that go to people who are undeserving
in some way under this umbrella of
the morality that they apply to who
deserves
something from the government of course
they're going to be against it
our new framework for understanding debt
and deficit
is that not every dollar of debt is
created equal
if we take on a dollar of debt to give a
really rich person
a tax break statistically most of that
money they save just sits in a bank
account with a relatively low
economic multiplier if we accrue
a dollar of debt in order to give
somebody a better education
which allows them to earn more later in
life paying more taxes into the
government
or if we take on a dollar of debt to
give someone health care
that doesn't otherwise have it so that
now they can get
um a preemptive treatment preventive
treatment
rather than going to the doctor when
they are already sick
and then they miss fewer days of work
and earn higher wages
you understand how there are stimulative
reasons for the government to deficit
spend
and less or un non-stimulative reasons
the framework here is that most of this
stuff
would have a higher economic multiplier
than just tax cuts for the rich
now do i think that this is going to
pass as proposed there's no way in hell
there's no way in hell because even
democrats are not
unanimously on board here with the
things
that joe biden is going to be proposing
so i think that
joe biden is very well positioned right
now
with the success of vaccination the
passage of the 1.9 trillion dollar
coveted stimulus joe biden
has a lot of political capital right now
we've been wondering how is he going to
choose to spend it
and it is going to be on this 2 trillion
plus now 1.8 trillion dollar package now
the the i am not looking for i
i think i'm committing we'll see i think
i'm committing
not to deal with the really predictable
right wing opposition
which is where are we going to get this
four trillion dollars it's just like i'm
tired of it i'm tired of it i've done
deep dives on exactly where we can cut
spending i've explained modern monetary
theory
and the reality about how a country's
debt is not the same as a household debt
we we've done it all
so if they're going to just come out and
say we just
we don't have the 4 trillion and we
can't keep quote printing money i'm so
tired of that maybe i'll address it in
passing
but i'm not going to address that in
detail i'm more interested
in hearing from republicans good faith
critiques
of why the spending specifically
is not a good investment in the future
of america like actually tell me
okay he wants to do free tuition on
community college
why is that bad it seems to me that it
is number one
a great alternative for four years to
four-year schools for people
for whom maybe that's not the best fit
it is a great feeder
to reduce the total cost for people who
ultimately do want to go to a four-year
school and earn a bachelor's degre
degree it seems economically stimulative
it will make us more competitive
tell me why it's a bad idea to spend
money on that rather than just throwing
at me what 4
4 trillion where's biden getting it come
on that's pathetic that's flaccid
it's a very uh flimsy criticism so i'm
hoping to engage more
substantively with criticisms that are
made in good faith
and that are not just the same old thing
we've heard time and time again that's
tonight joe biden will announce it
i will be live starting at 8 pm eastern
on youtube
twitch and facebook and i hope you'll
join me for that speech tonight
one of our sponsors today is strategic
voters a new podcast that features
election experts political campaign
strategists and everyday americans
who sit down and discuss the biggest
issues in the u.s
political landscape on the activism side
strategic voters as an organization
aims to encourage people to vote with
the benefit of the country
as a whole in mind instead of just
voting one party
down the ballot if you want to hear some
really different
and interesting opinions and approaches
to voting and viewing policies
give the strategic voters podcast a
listen
the latest two episodes feature rachel
cobb and lana atkinson as guests i've
been listening to it myself
i've been really enjoying it it's very
grassroots and independent which i love
find the strategic voters podcast on all
major podcast platforms and make sure to
follow them
on twitter at strategic voters